hbo max's sex in the city revival series
and just like that may have finished
airing weeks ago but cynthia nixon still
has something to say about fans quote
bizarre reaction to her character
miranda's evolution
it's shocking it's shocking
the 55 year old actress sits down with
vogue and gets candid about the mixed
feelings fans had to miranda's romance
with che diaz
i'm in love with you i am so in love
with you
and i want us to be together there's
definitely a lot to take in between
these two and the possibilities are
endless and miranda ending her marriage
to fan favorite steve brady in order to
pursue that relationship is this really
happening are you asking me for a
divorce
this is really happening we didn't come
back to do stuff that we'd already done
we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them
you know follow their hearts so how does
cynthia feel about the arguments that
her character has completely changed she
tells the mad quote i think that's a
bizarre reaction adding that she thinks
miranda is incredibly brave charging
forward and has always been a bull in a
china shop quote as miranda says we're
not old we're 55. i mean you're
certainly closer to the end than to the
beginning but if you're not happy with
where you are you still have a lot of
time to make a change am i not allowed
to change a little bit
or a lot
or change back again if i feel like it
do i have to follow my own rigid rules
until the day that i die yeah and all
that echoes what cynthia told et back in
december we're 55 it's a moment in
in women's lives where they often do
kind of reevaluate where they are
there's more behind me than there is
left but i'm still plenty young enough
that i could actually embark on a whole
new adventure the actress adds that the
series aims to quote show women and our
struggles and our dreams and our foibles
you don't always know where you're going
those are the people that i'm interested
in not the people who are playing it
safe we didn't come back to be boring
you didn't like us because we were
boring the first time you liked us
because we took chances and that's what
we're doing cynthia says she thinks fans
were looking for a rehash of the
original series and she says that if she
could do it all again she'd shout a very
specific message from the mountaintops
quote i would have made sure we said to
people in letters 10 feet tall this is
not sex in the city if you're looking
for sex in the city you should watch the
reruns this is a new show for this
moment and for the moment in these
original characters lives a sentiment
that reflects what her co-star sarah
jessica parker told e.t we felt excited
about
the kind of stories that we were
interested in telling we were curious as
to you know about where they were and
who they were and what was their life
like and who were they now surrounded by
but the question remains will fans get a
season two who knows what's going to
happen here's what cynthia and mario
cantone aka anthony teased to e.t i am
not a writer and so that is one of the
great privileges of not being a writer
is it's not my job to figure it out but
you know thank god i don't know what the
thing they don't tell me anything why is
that because
i got a big moat
are you hoping for a season two of
course i am but i'm very hoping for a
season two but you know
when it's announced you'll have me back
and we'll drink and
dance
[Music]
you